auf den spuren der söldner
aus welcher richtung
sie haben uns gesehen eine
verhängnisvolle recherche mein
kameramann wird von söldnern entführt
ich kann knapp entkommen es geht um
kriegsverbrechen
ich würde ihm sagen dass er ein mörder
ist
die privatisierung der schlachtfelder
russische söldner in der wüste von
libyen
[Musik]
und ein untergetauchter manager eines
deutschen dax konzerns der eine
söldnerarmee aufbauen wollte das ist
natürlich alles hochgradig zynisch aber
werde wirecard skandal begleitet weiß
nichts war bisher verrückt genug und
dann nicht am ende war zu sein
zdfzoom will wissen wie funktioniert das
geschäft mit dem krieg
wer verdient daran
ein für uns ungewöhnliches treffen mein
kameramann und ich bei einem zeichner er
verwandelt unsere erinnerung im bilde
skizziert was uns wochen zuvor passiert
ist rekonstruktion einer entführung die
sich so tatsächlich im september 2021 in
einer syrischen stadt ereignet hat
dann schaue ich mal einfach an oder
eigentlich wollten wir nur irgendwo wir
trinken sind raus aus dem hotel hat noch
keine kamera mit
200 300 meter von unserem hotel entfernt
kamen wir an einen checkpoint vorbei der
kontrolliert wurde von us-truppen
weg auch schon früher immer mal ein auto
vorbei und wussten auf keinen fall
stehen bleiben
und hörten dann aber wieso formierte
schon anfangen uns für sich zu rufen
eine überwachungskamera nimmt auf was
geschieht wenn ich sehe plötzlich wie
aus der anderen richtung und zivilist
kommt und er kam so auf uns zu und es
erinnert ich bin traurig auswahl auch
recht kräftig wirkte auf mich
das nächste was ich bemerkte war dass
mich jemand am arm packte über
meine schulter und sah dass der typ
trägt der uniform und hat mit
kalaschnikow mein letzter gedanke war da
noch vor dem standpunkt schwer
geschluckt haben hoffentlich die
kalaschnikow in den rücken zu schießen
fünfundzwanzigster september 10 uhr 43
gerald mein kameramann ist entführt von
söldnern des syrischen regimes
ich kann entkommen jetzt muss ich
entscheiden hinterherlaufen mein
kameramann alleine lassen oder hilfe
holen
in leipzig demonstrieren geflüchtete
gegen den söldner krieg in libyen gegen
menschen wie diese plante der vorstand
eines deutschen dax konzerns mit
privaten söldnern vorzugehen
um die hintergründe zu recherchieren
wenn wir auch nach syrien reisen
aber unsere recherche beginnt hier in
münchen es geht um einen skandal der auf
den ersten blick nichts mit krieg und
söldnern zu tun hat nach einem
milliardenschweren
bilanzbetrug brach im juni 2020 der
finanzdienstleister wirecard zusammen
vorstandsmitglied jan marschalek konnte
sich ins ausland absetzen seither wird
weltweit nach ihm gefahndet marschalek
führte offenbar ein doppelleben im
schattenreich von politik geheimdiensten
und militär unternehmen ein zeuge
erinnerte sich vor dem
untersuchungsausschuss das marschalek
2018 davon gesprochen hat gegen
geflüchtete in libyen eine söldnerarmee
aufstellen zu wollen 15 bis 20.000
söldner sollten die libysche grenze
abriegeln
[Musik]
fabio de masi saß für die linke im
wirecard untersuchungsausschuss vor
allem marschall ex interessen in libyen
geben nach wie vor rätsel auf dem
höhepunkt der über die flüchtlingskrise
waren eben auch ein tummelfeld für
verschiedene
mächte und jetzt über söldner armeen
sozusagen dann einfluss nehmen zu wollen
die ja häufig schlimmste
kriegsverbrechen begehen auf
fluchtrouten und ähnliches ist natürlich
im hohen maße für schon auch gegen
internationales recht das wahrscheinlich
beziehung zu selten hatte dafür gebe es
tatsächlich anhaltspunkte es gibt zwei
ganz interessante spuren einerseits soll
er kontakte gehabt haben
ich meine zu der russischen rsb group
das ist eine sondergruppe die dort
unterwegs und er soll
eben mit diesem unternehmen auch
beziehung gehabt haben das ergibt sich
auch aus seiner kommunikation
welche interessen hatte marschalek in
libyen und lassen sich verbindungen
finden zwischen dem wirecard chef und
der russischen rsb group gekonnten e
mails und messenger kommunikation von
marschalek auswerten haben mit zeugen
gesprochen das ergebnis marschalek war
nicht nur wirecard vorstand sondern auch
besitzer mehrere zementwerke in libyen
alles andere war recht einfach wir sind
auf die internetseite der rsb group in
moskau gegangen und das gibt es fotos
auch aus libyen sie zeigen sollten wie
sie einst moment werk sichern sie räumen
und munition und sie markieren immer
wieder die gemäuer mit einem schriftzug
oben steht minen und darunter sieht man
rsb grob das interessante daran ist dass
es ein ähnliches foto von
marschall ergibt da sieht man ihn wie er
vor einem tor steht und hinten an einer
mauer entdeckt man den schriftzug ihres
w group und minen ich denke das ist ein
beleg dafür dass er in libyen war und
einen hinweis darauf dass die rsb group
sein zementwerk von minen und munition
befreit hat es gibt aber noch was ein
vertrag zwischen wirecard und der rsb
group der vertrag sieht vor dass der rsb
group eine softwarelizenz bezahlt für
prepaidkarten und mit diesem prepaid
karten wollte die hsb group angeblich
löhne an die söldner auszahlen man kann
sagen ja einmalig hatte persönliche
interessen in libyen ihm gehörten
mehrere zementwerke die rsb group das
russische seltener unternehmen räumte
minen in diesen zementwerken und das
dritte ist war kabel selbst hatte
geschäftsbeziehung zur rsb group sie
hatten ihn eine lizenz für prepaid
karten verkauft
wir wollen mehr über die rsb group
heraus finden auf der internetseite des
russischen militär unternehmens sind die
kontaktdaten eines vertreters in
deutschland angegeben das angebliche
büro ein mietshaus im berliner stadtteil
tegel ich kann nicht sagen ich bin nur
ein hausmeister mehr erfahren wir hier
nicht wir fahren zu einem ehemaligen
geschäftsfreund von marschalek nachdem
marschalek abgetaucht ist soll er noch
kontakt zu ihm gehabt haben aber sagen
will auch der geschäftsfreund nichts
dann finden wir aber dennoch ein der
reden will unter der bedingung seine
identität zu schützen ist ein bekannter
von marschalek bereit mit mir zu
sprechen wir haben das treffen
nachgestellt mit der zeitschiene die
lust an wirecard verloren zu haben er
liebte das risiko das unternehmerische
risiko meine ich deshalb hatte er diese
zementwerke in libyen gekauft jan begann
sich zu verhindern einmal zeigt er mir
ein video auf dem telefon das waren ich
glaube söldner die zivilisten erschossen
ich habe ihm gesagt ja das will ich
nicht sehen seit 2014 trieb marschalek
für wirecard das projekt hat er wohl in
libyen voran der deutsche
finanzdienstleister
investierte in dem nordafrikanischen
bürgerkriegsland millionen in ein karten
bezahlsystem
im juni 2015 meldete wirecard vorstand
marschalek seinen kollegen eine kleine
erfolgsgeschichte aus dem kriegsgebiet
angehängt ein foto der lybischen partner
[Musik]
uno und die europäische union hatten
unter anderem finanzsanktionen gegen
libyen verhängt das sollte verhindern
dass waffen und söldner ins
bürgerkriegsland gelang und bezahlt
werden in bonn treffe ich andreas
heinemann grüder
wo kann das interesse liegen für
zahlungsdienstleister mit russischen
söldner unternehmen zusammenzuarbeiten
bzw was kann wirecard daran interessiert
mit bürgerkriegsland und
zahlungssystemen oft zu bauen natürlich
müssen sie
sagen
finanztransaktionen sicherstellen können
und wenn es nicht also direkt geht auf
ein russisches konto sondern über
irgendwelche korrespondenz banken damit
unterliegen sie der finanzaufsicht und
man versucht aus diesem system
auszusteigen und zahlungssysteme zu
bekommen die eben nicht nachvollziehbar
sind ein verdacht wirecard als
heimlicher zahlungsabwickler der söldner
1 500 seiten starker bericht des un
sicherheitsrats von märz 2021 beschreibt
und belegt wie der krieg der geister
armeen in libyen funktioniert geheime
truppentransporte für russische sollten
an der berüchtigten wagner group ihr
chef ein kriminal geschäftsmann
geschmückte flugzeuge aus europa
auftraggeber ein berüchtigter us söldner
bezahlt über briefkastenfirmen in
steueroasen
eine schatten infrastruktur die dazu
dient sanktionen zu umgehen
und noch eine überraschung marschall xi
de flüchtlinge auf ihrem weg nach europa
mit söldnern zu stoppen war nicht neu
[Musik]
die lösung ist die flüchtlingskrise
lässt sich nur an der südgrenze von
libyen stoppen die söldner oder die
ausländischen kräfte bilden die basis
auf der dann eine libysche grenzpolizei
aufgebaut wird
der ehemalige chef des berüchtigten us
söldner unternehmens blackwater erik
prince 2017 im interview mit cnn die
vereinten nationen dürfen prinz vor in
libyen gegen sanktionen verstossen zu
haben seine geschäftsidee privatarmeen
könnten in libyen flüchtlinge stoppen
scheiterte letztlich an der finanzierung
auffällig die söldner pläne von prinz
deckten sich mit den von jahren
marschalek
der fall wirecard beschäftigte auch das
österreichische parlament marschalek
hatte beste beziehungen zur
rechtspopulistischen fpö zur
österreichischen militärvertretern und
ex geheimdienstler
dann kam plötzlich irgendwie ein
komisches bezug heraus mit russland um
ein projekt wo ja mit 15.000 söldner
nach libyen stellen wollte sozusagen die
mittelmeer oder zu schließen und das war
natürlich attraktiv und das ist
natürlich für jeden politiker in dieser
zeit wo die rechtsnationalen in europa
gestärkt wurden natürlich eine
interessante
das vorstandsmitglied eines deutschen
dax-unternehmens wollte eine
söldnerarmee in libyen aufstellen er
wollte in das geschäft mit dem krieg
einsteigen doch wo kommen die
söldnerheer
spuren führen nach syrien wir wollen
recherchieren wie söldner rekrutiert
werden und dabei kommen wir ihnen
ungewollt nach mein kameramann wird von
ihnen entführt
denn aus erinnerung bilder werden das
geschehen dass die überwachungskamera
nicht mehr erfassen konnte der
augenblick kurz nach der entführung
[Musik]
ich bin dann zurück ins hotel und habe
versucht hilfe zu rufen die haben mich
dann über hinterhöfe ein auto dann ein
gibt es hat nur noch die augen mir dann
noch im auto mein eigenes t shirt über
den kopf gezogen wir sind dann
irgendwohin gefahren ich hatte so ein
gefühl noch nie gehabt dass irgendwo
hingefahren wirst das nicht siehst und
das ist glaube das allerschlimmste wenn
du die gefahren nicht sehen kannst es
war einfach so ein gefühl der
machtlosigkeit muss man ganz ehrlich
sagen dass ich noch bis heute
zurück in der hotellobby ich habe
kontakt leute von der entführung eines
kameramanns informiert ein vertreter der
kurden versprach hilfe und warnte assad
kämpfer könnten versuchen mich aus dem
hotel zu holen währenddessen wird mein
entführte kameramann zu einem geheimen
stützpunkt des regimes gefahren
und danach mission gebäude gebracht das
gebäude war wirklich groß weil ich dort
ewig durch das gebäude geschoben wurden
und da hat man angefangen mich zu
verhören
ob syrien libyen mali oder die
zentralafrikanische republik die kriege
der gegenwart werden vor allem von
söldnern geführt es sind russische
schatten armeen die immer stärker auf
dem markt der privaten
militärdienstleister drängen die
kriegsführung im einundzwanzigsten
jahrhundert
verändert sich deutlich von der art der
kriegsführung
das 20 jahrhundert geprägt hat und diese
privaten militärfirmen sind ein teil
davon
wie sieht er aus der krieg der söldner
und welchen einfluss hat die
privatisierung der schlachtfelder auf
das völkerrecht und die verfolgung der
kriegsverbrechen
auf der suche nach antworten überqueren
wir ende september die irakisch syrische
grenze noch eine ich nicht wie
gefährlich nah wir wenige tage später
einer söldnergruppe kommen würden die
frontlinien des vor zehn jahren
ausgebrochenen krieges in syrien sind
zahlreich und längst mit das ausland mit
die lage grob skizziert machthaber
baschar assad führt krieg gegen die
regime gegner russland und der iran
stehen ihm dabei zur seite die kurden
bekämpfen die terror miliz des
islamischen staats und gelten als
verbündete des westens auch die türkei
ist in den krieg involviert ihr gegner
die syrischen kurden
die vereinten nationen und
menschenrechtsorganisationen beklagen
dass syrien längst nicht mehr nur
schlachtfeld sondern inzwischen auch
aufmarsch und rekrutierungs gebiet für
russische und türkische söldnerfirmen
ist unterwegs mit kurdischen kämpfern
ein dorf in der nähe der syrischen stadt
tall hassaka markiert eine der vielen
fronten wenige kilometer entfernt sollen
stellung der türkischen kämpfer sein
unser begleiter erzielt das sollte er
darunter sein was sind das für söldner
wo kommen die her freunde ermunterten
sie sind seltener und kommen aus
verschiedenen ordnen zu gehen überall
hin
sie müssen nicht an ihrem ort kämpfen
sie stammen aus unterschiedlichen
syrischen städten manche waren vorher
sogar beim es
jetzt sind sie im türkischen auftrag
unterwegs sie hatten nur die uniform und
die flagge getauscht
lassen sie uns runter gehen
die haben uns gesehen
am himmel tauchen kampfhubschrauber auf
beziehen es vor aus dem ort zu
verschwinden
es ist ein skrupelloses spiel mit der
armut und perspektivlosigkeit der
menschen laut den vereinten nationen
rekrutiert auch eine türkische militär
firma syrer als söldner für verdeckte
operationen im ausland
in syrien haben rekrutiere ein leichtes
spiel
in den vergangenen 10 kriegsjahren
starben mehr als 600.000 menschen viele
syrer haben ihre existenz verloren leben
in armut auch in kamishli die stadt ist
das zentrum der syrischen kurden
noch vor monaten lieferten sich kurden
kämpfer und regime anhänger blutige
straßenschlachten
offiziell herrscht waffenruhe doch sie
ist brüchig wir drehen heimlich vom dach
eines hochhauses es ist ein strategisch
wichtiger punkt von hier aus ist der
flughafen zu sehen gemeinsam mit
us-truppen betreiben hier russische
streitkräfte eine militärbasis sie
unterhalten eine luftbrücke in 700
kilometer entfernte damaskus hauptstadt
des syrischen regimes
wir bekommen kontakt zu einem syrer der
sich als söldner für ein einsatz in
lügen anwerben ließ
ich meine ich kriege für fünf monate
einsatz in libyen 5000 dollar
der krieg hat sie arm gemacht und die
armut zwingt sie in neue kriege neben
türkischen militär unternehmen werben
vor allem russische schatten armeen um
syrische männer ihre operationsgebiet
sind auch kriegs- und krisengebiete
außerhalb syriens
ich habe mich damals bei der russischen
wagner group beworben das lief über
vermittler es gibt vermittler büros und
dort kann man sich bewerben
[Musik]
die syrer hat sich von dem russischen
söldner unternehmen wagner anwerben
lassen vermittler rekrutierten ihn in
whatsapp gruppen
intimer libyen der lohn ist 1500 dollar
und für die bewachung eines lagers
bekommt ihr 800 dollar
[Applaus]
sie stimmen sich auf den kampf ein das
video wurde uns zugespielt es zeigt
angeworbene syrische söldner die beiden
männer in der mitte rekrutieren für das
russische militär unternehmen wagner ob
einige von ihnen werden als söldner in
syrien eingesetzt andere werden nach
libyen geschickt
ich bin direkt mit einem russischen
flugzeug nach libyen geflogen bei mir
ging das sehr schnell vier stunden nach
vertragsunterzeichnung war der abflug
wir sind voll attackieren die libysche
stadt bengasi geflogen im flugzeug waren
wir zwischen 100 und 150 leute
was in libyen erwartet nur allzu oft tot
und verstümmelung
an einem geheimen ort in der syrischen
stadt kamischke wird mein kameramann von
söldnern verhört
und dann hat man irgendwie angefangen
mir fragen zu stellen dass buffett ein
ganz wichtiges thema gewesen
irgendwelche namen von kunden zu
bekommen die uns tut irgendwie geholfen
hatten das war immer wieder dass das
thema wie sind die namen von wiesen den
namen von eures trainer verstanden auch
kein spaß also das muss man ganz ehrlich
sagen das waren profis
tage vor der entführung immer wieder
fahren wir in kamishli an checkpoints
vorbei die nicht von den kurden
kontrolliert werden es sind jene söldner
des assad-regimes die mein kameramann
kidnappen werden die männer gehören den
nationalen verteidigungskräfte namco zdf
nachdem es im frühjahr
2021 wiederholt zu blutigen
zusammenstößen zwischen nef und kurden
kam herrscht in kamishli eine brüchige
waffenruhe
die ndf miliz des regimes ist berüchtigt
2012 gründete der syrische geschäftsmann
fabia sakhir die paramilitärische
organisation ein foto zeigt ihn an der
seite des syrischen machthabers assad
menschenrechtsorganisationen werfen der
miliz zahlreiche kriegsverbrechen vor
entführungen folter und erschießungen
human rights watch macht die ndf
mitverantwortlich für ein massaker an
mehr als 160 zivilisten in den syrischen
orten al baida und banja
[Musik]
mein kameramann befindet sich in den
händen der ndf um die sprachbarriere zu
überwinden nutzen die söldner ein google
translator auf ihrem telefon
das komische ist wenn du mir das jetzt
so vorspiel ist ja da kommt wie sie bei
mir auf weil das immer genau die gleiche
stimme war die dort auch mich immer
gefragt hat und dessen englisch oder
deutsch das waren englisch gewesen
als sie dann merkten dass sie
mit ihren fragen nicht weiterkommen das
werde ich nie vergessen dann kam dann
auf englisch die anlage hat und foltern
tätig
nachdem sie angekündigt hat mich zu
foltern protection anderes zimmer
gebracht und was dort wirklich
beängstigend war war dass die mich da
auf den stuhl gesetzt haben in der
schule hatte keine lehner und das war
wohl im moment wird gedacht habe jetzt
haben sie mich mögliche nachfolger
kammer gestellt und jetzt geht die voll
rein und
[Musik]
wir nennen das einen deutschen stuhl es
ist ein folterwerkzeug in syrien können
wir das schon seit langem die stasi hat
assad vater gelehrt wie man einen
sicherheitsstaat aufbaut sie wollen dich
in angst zustände versetzen die ganze
zeit jede sekunde zum schluss brechen
sie die das rückgrat
der 60-jährige syrische
menschenrechtsanwalt anwar al buri kennt
die foltermethoden einen monat nach der
entführung in syrien treffe ich ihn in
berlin ich will wissen warum die ndf
kämpfer söldner sind
sie gut weil sie es sind weil sie nicht
gekommen sind um für prinzipien zu
kämpfen sie kämpfen für geld und die
meisten von ihnen sind kriminelle
normale kriminelle baschar al assad hat
sie aus den gefängnissen freigelassen
und die wachen glücklich denn jetzt
konnten sie verbrechen begehen und
niemand kann ihn etwas
an boni gehört zu einer gruppe anwältin
die us schuldner vor gericht bringen
einige hatten sich nach deutschland
abgesetzt
ihre menschenrechtsverletzungen soll
nicht ungeahndet bleiben
söldner verbrechen wie schwer sie zu
verfolgen sind zeigt dieser fall dass
handy video entstand 2017 in syrien
von den tätern selbst gedreht es zeigt
die bestialische ermordung eines syrers
journalisten aus russland konnten die
täter identifizieren es sind söldner der
russischen wagner group in einem vorort
von amsterdam lebt der cousin des
mordopfers der getötete heißt mohammed
taha ismael al-abdulla wie der vater von
vier kindern in die hände der russischen
söldner geraten konnten sei unklar
die war im libanon und kam zurück nach
syrien
das assad regime hat ihn festgenommen
und zur armee geschickt
sie haben ihn für die bewachung des
flughafens akkurat eingeteilt
23 monate war er dann
die familie hatte keinen kontakt zu ihm
eine video nachricht als letztes
lebenszeichen
ich habe ein video bekommen ramadi hat
das aufgenommen bevor er nach syrien
zurück haben er spricht mit seinen
kindern ich komme zu euch zum zuckerfest
und verspricht seinem sohn dass er ihn
fahrrad von ihm bekommt
die familie hat nicht einmal die leiche
ihres ermordeten angehörigen erhalten
die russischen söldner sind bislang
unbehelligt geblieben mein kameramann
befindet sich noch immer in den händen
der us söldner jetzt schon fast sechs
stunden
bislang gibt es kein lebenszeichen von
ihm
es war auch genau der zeitpunkt als dann
das telefon aus war wo ich dachte okay
wäre das der akku unter im schlechtesten
fall sind jetzt gerade dabei ist ein
telefon auseinanderzunehmen eine
kollegin aus kamishli und ein vertreter
der kurden sind in meinem hotelzimmer
gekommen sie raten den fall vorerst
nicht öffentlich zu machen beide stehen
in engem kontakt zu einer
verhandlungsgruppe die leute angefangen
manche spekulieren
dass er eventuell nach damaskus gebracht
wird eine befürchtung die man auch im
auswärtigen amt teilt dass wir
inzwischen informiert haben
zur selben zeit in dem geheimen
stützpunkt des assad regimes
die haben wir die maske abgenommen und
da saß ich einen riesengroßen büro und
das ganze büro war gepflastert
was hat die stadt aus allen ecken an
vorne sitzt man an dem sprießen großen
schreibtisch mit sechs festnetztelefon
drauf und sagt ich spiele hier beim
sicherheitsdienst von syrien und hat
dann weiter versucht mich zu fragen wir
haben wir geholfen hat die gleichen
fragen die ich dann die ganze zeit schon
gestellt bekommen habe wie gesagt diese
ganze szenerie dort war schon vor stress
und ein russischer general mit zwei
leibwächtern betrat den raum
wirklich gedauert jetzt mischen sich die
russen noch mit einem helfen schnell weg
zu bringen wohin auch immer seit der
entführung durch die us söldner sind
mehr als zehn stunden vergangen jetzt
nur 30 der welt hat sich gemeldet das
erste mal ihm geht's gut es gibt wohl
russischen unterhändler es ist mir schon
die ganze zeit
[Musik]
und dann hat man mich im
pickup reingesetzt vorsatz der russische
general ich saß hinten mit einem schwer
bewachten
russische fahne wehte standort vom hof
gefahren
gegen 2 uhr die erlösende nachricht mein
kameramann ist frei kidnapping verhöre
und folterandrohung liegen nun hinter
ihm nur sein status als deutscher hat
ihn gerettet
die privatisierung der kriege schreitet
voran wenn söldner kriegsverbrechen
begehen müssen diese verfolgt werden und
wenn ein vorstandsmitglied eines
dax-unternehmens offensichtlich
unbemerkt von behörden die absicht hatte
eine söldnerarmee aufzustellen dann ist
das ein skandal
[Musik]
[Applaus]